after a thorough investigation through
all of the streaming services seediest
back alleys were now ready to present
our findings which of these hidden gem
mystery films will be your new favorites
mani good detective will tell you that
it's always the one you least expect
director Paul Feig is best known for
loose improv driven comedies like
bridesmaids in 2016's ghostbusters
that's why you might be surprised to
learn that in 2018 he broke from his
formal style for the most meticulously
crafted film of his career if you missed
the simple favor when it was in theaters
check it out it might be his best work
yet Anna Kendrick plays lonely single
mom Stephanie smothers her best friend
Emily played by Blake Lively seems to
have it all a lucrative job a loving
husband and above all confidence one day
Emily asked Stephanie for a simple favor
to look after her son for a few hours
while she feels with a work crisis
stephanie agrees and that Emily goes
missing after the police finally give up
the search Stephanie decides to take the
investigation into her own hands we
don't want to ruin any of the later plot
twists so let's just say that as
Stephanie digs deeper she discovers
another side to her friend that she kept
hidden from the rest of the world well
written and well acted a simple favor is
what would happen if gone girl was
allowed to be funny sometimes and this
wonderful gem of a movie is definitely
worth a watch set during the Japanese
occupation of Korea the handmaiden tells
the story of a Korean servant named
Sookie who is hired by a Japanese
heiress named pity ko what hit eco
doesn't know is that her new handmaiden
has a secret Sookie is actually a
skilled beat a partner of a con artist
with the pseudonym count Fujiwara the
count plans to seduce hit eco and steal
her fortune and it's Sookie's job to
befriend the lady then persuade her to
marry Fujiwara when the proper moment
comes
but as Sookie gets to know her mistress
better she starts to have doubts about
the counts dastardly plan and that's
just the first half hour from there
things get really wild we won't spoil
anything but let's just say that Count
Fujiwara has been hiding certain facts
from Sookie about the nature of his plan
and hid eco herself also has her fair
share of dark secrets
sometimes mystery films lose a bit of
their spark after the first time you see
them the handmaiden essentially
beautifully constructed and
intelligently written film that it just
gets better every time you watch it this
multifaceted masterpiece alternates
between thrilling terrifying sensual and
Hilaire
but no matter how many twists and turns
the story takes it always remains deeply
human many of the movies were discussing
here are classics of the mystery genre
if you're looking for a more recent film
how about one that was released in March
2020 directed Amazon Prime blow the man
down opens in the small town of Easter
Cove where a straight-laced sisters
Priscilla and Mary Beth are attending
their mother's funeral
after the ceremony Mary Beth visits afar
to drown our sorrows and while there she
meets a handsome stranger this man
however isn't everything he seems and
their encounter ends with Mary Beth
accidentally implicated in a terrible
crime she calls her sister for guidance
and Priscilla agrees to help erase the
evidence of what Mary Beth has done as
the two sisters work to keep their own
secret hidden they end up discovering
the secrets of some of their neighbors
uncovering a dark criminal underbelly of
their sleepy hometown they soon find
themselves surrounded by an array of
deadly enemies and perhaps also some new
unlikely allies there's so much to love
about blow the man down it's beautifully
shots and smartly written for perhaps
best of all is the acting if you're
somewhat underwhelmed by the film's
sluggish first act stick with it blow
the man down really digs into high gear
about a half-hour end and it's one hell
of a ride from there to finish what
helpless think she's on her way to
church maybe you've seen a David Lynch
movie before you know that's simply
summarizing the plots of his films
doesn't do that justice that being said
let's talk about blue velvet while
walking home one day lovably Square
college student Jeffrey Beaumont finds a
severed human ear lying in a vacant lot
yes that's a human ear alright
immediately hands it over to the police
but he is unable to stop thinking about
how it got there and starts
investigating the mystery alongside his
friend sandy Williams the daughter of a
police detective Jeffrey decides to
sneak into the apartment of a woman
believed to be connected to the case and
once inside let's just say that he
discovers he's been living on the
precipice of a vast darkness and now
he's tumbled headfirst over the edge
into a cruel and disturbing world that
he might never be able to fully return
from like all of Lynch's films blue
velvet is surreal funny and darkly
mesmerizing it's also at times intensely
disturbing if you're not willing to sit
through that we encourage you to do what
Jeffrey should have done leave this
particular severed ear of a film lying
on the ground
and proceed on with your life as if you
never found it the conversation tells
the story of Harry call a private
security expert who lives a life of
isolation desperately avoiding
developing close relationships with the
people in his life for fear of his own
security
although call is frequently hired to
record the conversations of strangers he
tries not to pay attention to the
subject matter or think about the way
his work could be used to hurt people
one day Harry is hired by a mysterious
client to record a young couples
conversation as they walk through a
public park as call analyzes the
recording he begins to suspect that he
himself is being followed and that his
conversations are now being bugged by
some definitions the conversation
doesn't really qualify as a traditional
mystery Francis Ford Coppola stale
certainly has a compelling question at
the heart of it but it lacks many of the
other traditional elements of the genre
it's slow moody and far more of a
character study than a regular whodunit
but nonetheless it's a truly captivating
story so if you've got a hankering for
some moody 70's noir we highly recommend
checking it out if you like a little
horror mixed in with your mystery you
should definitely check out the
beautiful sci-fi thriller annihilation
Natalie Portman plays Lena a biologist
and former soldier one night her husband
a soldier named Cain mysteriously
appears in their house with no idea how
he got there despite the fact that he
was allegedly away on a classified
assignment he then collapses seemingly
ill government forces soon arrive on the
scene and they take Lena and Cain to a
government facility once there Lena is
told that they're on the border of an
enigmatic region of American coastline
that has been designated the shimmer
inexplicable phenomena have been
occurring in the area and any soldiers
who enter the shimmer never return
except for Lena's husband who remains in
critical condition another team is
assembled to explore the shimmer and
Lena volunteers to come along her team
then enters a strange glittering
landscape where the plants and animals
have mutated into new beautiful and
deadly alien species as they venture
deeper into the shimmer Lena's team
begins to suspect that their own bodies
and minds are starting to change as well
despite being a mind-blowing the
beautiful and thought-provoking film
annihilation was a bit of a box-office
dud but if you missed it in theaters
like so many other people you can make
up for that by checking it out on Amazon
Prime though some of these mystery
movies are older classics our next
selection is from 2019 though you won't
be able to tell by looking at it
the lighthouse was shot in black and
white using camera lenses from the 1930s
and an almost square aspect ratio that
harkens back to the days before
widescreen if Willem Dafoe and Robert
Pattinson weren't the two leads you
might really think it was a
hundred-year-old
bill sometime in the 1890s two men
arrived on a remote island season
lighthouse keeper Thomas Wake and his
new apprentice Ephraim Winslow hello
Reid our Father the Sea King rise from
the depths full foul in his fury
the men have a four week contract to
maintain the islands lighthouse and
apart from each other they'll be utterly
alone the four weeks
Efram and thomas tried to be friends at
first but continually end up putting
heads over their duties Ephraim also
learned that Thomas's last assistant
apparently died after losing his mind
over the following weeks ephraim himself
begins to see inexplicable things that
he keeps hidden from thomas then a storm
hits the island and everything gets much
worse if the captivating script and the
dynamic acting weren't enough both are
elevated to truly memorable heights by
the lighthouses tremendous
cinematography it's a perfect choice for
a claustrophobic mystery where you often
feel like you're not seeing the whole
picture
if midway through your mystery binge all
these dour stories about the dark side
of humanity have got you feeling down
why not try lightening the mood a little
with this selection based on the classic
board game the 1985 film clue is equal
parts classic murder mystery and
ensemble comedy farce six strangers are
gathered together for a dinner party in
a swanky New England mansion by a
mysterious man named mr. Boddy during
dinner the lights go out when they come
back on the six guests find that body
has been killed maybe he was poisoned
before the night is over the motley crew
needs to figure out which one of them is
the culprit before they can escape and
kill again
with a cast consisting of multiple
hilarious actors all at the top of their
game Clue is a truly great comedy as
well as a genuinely solid murder mystery
but above all it's just plain fun
wait I didn't know why would he don't
want to kill him please
seems so unnecessary that's what we call
overkill what we call a psychotic if you
haven't seen it before do yourself a
favor there's a reason this little film
became a late-night comedy cult classic
if you're looking for a classic murder
mystery it doesn't get much more classic
than the 1974 film Murder on the Orient
Express an adaptation of the Agatha
Christie novel by the same name
featuring many of the biggest stars of
the 70s having just solved a case famous
detective Hercule Poirot is on his way
home aboard the train known as the
Orient Express
while Rowe spends his evening getting to
know a collection of eclectic
international passengers in the morning
the passengers discover two chilling
surprises the first is that the train is
stopped due to a heavy snowfall blocking
the tracks the second is that an
American businessman named mr. Ratchett
has been murdered
sleep while Rowe vials to solve the case
and given that the Train can't go
anywhere from the time being he has all
the time he needs to conduct a series of
interviews with the various passengers
about their potential motives while ro
slowly puts together the pieces of what
is most assuredly one of the most
absurdly complex and multi-layered
locked-room mysteries in the history of
detective fiction and one that we're
sure you'll never forget check out one
of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the BAL so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]